I was a high school computer science
teacher for 17 years I taught at Bishop
O'Dowd High School in Oakland California
and I did like I taught during the
dot-com boom I taught during the dot-com
bust and I taught during sort of the the
recovery of the tech industry afterwards
and I did see the interest in when I was
teaching fluctuate it would go up and
down every year largely tied to the
economy which is a little bit weird to
me and even as a school you know when I
began to teach in the late 90s the
school itself actually had a computer
requirement you were required to take a
certain number of computer classes
before you were allowed to graduate they
got rid of that requirement they got rid
of that requirement because at some
point they felt like computer literacy
was so important that it ought to be
integrated in all the other subjects so
it shouldn't be a thing in and of itself
so in the beginning I agreed with that
but after seeing how it played out I
don't think it was as effective as we
wanted it to be you know I think that
computers are still a fairly specialized
type of knowledge computer science and
and teachers today still and I don't
think I don't think we've been trained
on how to integrate computer science
well into the other subjects so
ultimately what ended up happening at
that school site was we would graduate
students who would know how to use
computers but would not necessarily
understand how they work or even
understand how to how to maximize what
they could get out of out of the
computer as a computer science teacher
something I used to talk to parents
about especially during the dot-com bust
when interest in my class started to
evaporate his coding is not about
training students how to type into a
computer that's that's the least of it
coding is actually really about training
students to think in a certain way it's
about training students to take
large and complex problems and break
them up into small pieces it's about
training students to take things that
are vague that are difficult to wrap
your mind around and putting them into
concrete sequential steps and that sort
of thinking that sort of skill that sort
of mental skill is applicable no matter
what you do in life you know what you're
talking about right now you know about
how the future economy is going to
require more knowledge work we don't
know what computers are going to look
like right we don't we don't know we
don't even know what coding is going to
look like but I can guarantee you that
that that the the coding mentality that
the type of thinking that's required in
order to code well that will become
increasingly valuable as we go on and I
think when you when you teach kids
computer science you are touching on a
lot of principles of logic and and in
terms of you know students knowing how
to use computers but not necessarily
understanding why they work I think
that's largely a product of a success of
the computer field you know within
computer science there's this idea of
abstraction where you separate the
interface of something from the
internals of it and that's something
that I talked about in my computer
science classes when I was teaching you
do that because it makes the computer
itself it makes whatever you're making
easier to use right the user just has to
have like a working mental model of what
the interface looks like they don't have
to know anything about the guts
underneath but unfortunately what you
miss out on in that is the the mental
development in your thinking that comes
with understanding the guts right when
you understand the guts it's not just
for using that tool it's actually to
change what's inside of your skull it's
actually to change your brain it makes
you a better thinking or makes you a
better problem solver to understand
those things so I think there's a place
I think there's a place for abstraction
but my hope is that every student before
they graduate from high school they'll
have a chance to wrestle with those guts
to be able to really understand how a
computer works from the inside how both
software and hardware work
on the inside
[Music]